so i don't know if you know this about
me uh i'm actually very uninformed on
what you know about me but i love quotes
i'm a big fan of quotes and i've
actually collected some of my favorites
that you might not be aware of that
we've thrown together into a little
segment that i like to call quotables
you want to play quotables
let's play quotables let's take a look
at this first one here this is a quote
what's your favorite jack johnson song
that one is uh jack johnson on a first
date
yeah sure this one is a quote
django
chained it's a movie executive pitching
a prequel no one wants
quote
thar she blows
this one's a bit of a twist this is yoda
finding out his girlfriend is cheating
on him with a guy named zar
breaks my heart she does
you know for as much as i committed to
that impression you think it would have
yielded better results
never when i ask for it
quote check out zach galifa napkins over
here
that one's gonna be me if i ever see a
bearded man holding a lot of napkins
i feel like i feel like that'll play
this one's a little bit different quote
man but what about the single set of
footprints in the sand
jesus
that's when i carried you
and this hand print is when i did a
sweet cartwheel
if you're not laughing you're not
picturing a robed jesus
putting down the man and being like just
one for me
i swear to god i will attack you
quote you guys want to go make noise and
everywhere
this one is gary leader of the geese
having their morning meeting
uh here's a fun one uh quote free bird
free bird
it's a man having a really hard time
giving away a parrot at a leonard
skynyrd concert
it's a bad
it's a bad place to try and give away a
bird
i'll explain some of the jokes
this one's fun quote an active mind
cannot exist in an inactive body that's
just a real one from general george
patton
hold on
stephen hawking
valid point
and finally quote
i would have given them to you
this one is a tearful ronald mcdonald at
hamburglar's execution
why is he being executed for petty fails
patty theft